>> ONE OF AMERICA'S WORST
LAWYERS GOING DOWN THE WAY HE
CAME IN.
HE CLAIMS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE SAYS IT'S POLITICAL REVENGE
THAT HAS TRUMP'S FINGERPRINTS
ALL OVER IT.
AVENATTI FACING MULTIPLE FEDERAL
CHARGES AND 400 YEARS IN PRISON.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA LOOKING LIKE
FOOLS AFTER PUTTING AVENATTI ON
TV 254 TEAMS IN THE YEAR LEADING
UP TO THIS.
A QUICK LOOK BACK.
>> HE'S DONALD TRUMP'S WORST
NIGHTMARE.
>> JOINING SUS-MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI IS SAVING
THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU'RE SOMETHING OF A FOLKS
HERO NOW.
>> I OWE MICHAEL AVENATTI AN
APOLOGY.
I SAY ENOUGH ALREADY.
I'VE SEEN YOU EVERYWHERE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE LEFT TO SAY?
YOU HAVE A LOT TO SAY.
>> WE THINK YOU GUYS ARE THE TIP
OF THE SPEAR THAT WILL TAKE DOWN
DONALD TRUMP.
>> LET'S GET INTO HIS HEAD,
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> OH.
>> A LOT OF ROOM.
>> WHAT MAKES HIM SAY, DO YOU
THINK, THAT HE BELIEVES THAT
TRUMP IS RESPONSIBLE?
>> I THINK HE'S ABOUT 28 DAYS
AWAY FROM AN INSANITY DEFENSE.
REALLY, IT'S BIZARRE.
LOOK AT ALL OF THE EVIDENCE.
>> THERE'S NO STRATEGY BEHIND
THAT?
>> IS DONALD TRUMP RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE FACT THAT HE DEFRAUDED
THE CLIENT THAT WAS DISABLED?
>> YEARS BEFORE THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
>> NO.
THE DOJ HAS VERY GOOD LAWYERS
WHO LOOKED AT, THIS THE MEDIA
DID NOT.
>> HAS THE MEDIA SAID ANYTHING?
>> OH, MAN.
IT'S PATHETIC HOW QUIET THEY
ARE.
STEPHANIE SHOULD ADDRESS -- SHE
CALLED HIM BROTHER.
ISN'T THAT SWEET?
HE'S A SCUM.
THEY EMBRACE HIM.
YOU KNOW WHY?
IT'S THE HIS CREDIT.
HE SHOWED HOW EASY IT IS TO
COMMANDEER THE MEDIA.
WHAT WERE THEIR WEAKNESSES?
TO RUIN TRUMP AND KAVANAUGH.
HE JUMPED ON THE HORSE AND RODE
IT TO CNN'S GUEST HEAP.
BUT THEY SHOULD -- THEY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS THE
MISTAKES.
I HAVE DONE THAT.
WHEN I MAKE A MISTAKE -- JESSE,
YOU DO IT ALMOST EVERY DAY.
>> NEVER.
>> I HAD A GOOD POINT.
HE SAID TRUMP HAD HIS FINGER
PRINTS ALL OVER IT FROM A
REPUBLICAN CLOSE TO TRUMP.
THERE'S NO REPUBLICAN GOING TO
TALK TO AVENATTI.
HE'S A FULL GROWN LIAR AND HE'S
GETTING 400 YEARS.
HE'S NOT THE TALIBAN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> TO YOUR POINT ABOUT OWNING UP
TO MISTAKES.
LET'S SAY TO SOMEONE THAT I
HAVE -- LET'S SAY SEBASTIAN
GORKA.
LET'S SAY SEBASTIAN GORKA WAS
HIT WITH MULTIPLE FELONY
CHARGES.
I'M USING THIS AS AN ANALOGY.
HE'S BEEN ON MY SHOW MULTIPLE
TIMES.
DON'T YOU THINK I WOULD TAKE A
MOMENT TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
SEBASTIAN GORKA WHEN HAD BEEN ON
MY SHOW FOR HOURS THAT WAS
INVOLVED IN SOMETHING --
>> MAYBE USE A MADE-UP NAME.
>> AND I HAVE NO IDEA THAT HE
BROKE A LAW.
>> DON'T YOU THINK THE MEDIA
NEEDS TO TAKE OWNERSHIP OF THIS?
>> I'M NOT CONFIDENT YOU WOULD
DO THE SAME.
>> YES.
>> BUT IT WASN'T JUST CNN.
ANNA NAVARRO ON THE VIEW WAS
SAYING HE WAS THE HOLY SPIRIT,
SAVING THE COUNTRY.
AND THEY SAID IT'S TRUMP'S
FAULT.
WHETHER THERE'S A STRATEGY
THERE.
IF HE SAYS IT'S TRUMP FAULT, THE
MEDIA WILL JUMP ON IT.
>> AND RALLIES THE MEDIA.
>> AND WHO ELSE IS DELUSIONAL,
SMOLLETT.
THERE YOU GO.
>> JUAN?
>> I'M STILL SURPRISED THAT ALL
OF YOU BLAMING THE MEDIA.
I THINK EVERY MEDIA IN AMERICA
THOUGHT THIS WAS A SALACIOUS
CASE WHERE HE WAS REPRESENTING A
PORN STAR THAT --
>> THAT HE STOLE FROM.
>> A MAN THAT TURNED OUT TO BE
PRESIDENT AND HAD AN AFFAIR WITH
HER AND TURNS OUT THERE WAS A
PAY-OFF AND A CHECK SIGNED BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IF YOUR A JOURNALIST AND YOU
DON'T COVER THAT, YOU'RE
NEGLIGENT.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU FELL FOR
AVENATTI.
>> HANG ON.
>> BUT SO ABSOLUTELY COVERED
THAT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
SAY HE'S NEXT TO JESUS OR HE IS
YOUR BROTHER OR THAT HE'S GOING
TO BE A SAVIOR.
YOU'RE THE LAWYER FOR THE
PERSON --
>> HE'S THE LAWYER AND HE GETS
ON TV.
THE CHECK SHOWS UP.
THE CHECK IS SIGNED BY DONALD
TRUMP.
GEE, I THINK SOME OF THE
EVIDENCE DID SHOW UP.
>> THAT'S WHY THEY FELL FOR HIM.
THEY LOVE THAT STORY.
THEY FELL FOR HIM.
>> YOU'RE SAYING THEY'RE
ANTI-TRUMP.
THAT'S WHY.
I DON'T CARE WHO THE PRESIDENT
WAS.
BILL CLINTON AND MONICA
LEWINSKY, STORMY DANIELS, DONALD
TRUMP, THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT WRONG TO SAY PUT
AVENATTI ON TV.
>> HE WASN'T VETTED.
>> HOW DO YOU VET A LATER?
>> IT'S NEWS WORSE THINK THAT HE
REPRESENTED STORMY DANIELS, BUT
MEDIA MADE HIM A CELEBRITY
EXPERT LAWYER AND TRIED TO
DESTROY KAVANAUGH'S LIFE BY GANG
RAPE AND THEN REFERRED FOR LYING
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE POLITICAL
AISLE.
SO JUST STOP WITH THE CASE ABOUT
STORMY DANIELS, WHICH SURE,
NEWSWORTHY BUT EXTENDED TO SMEAR
THE SUPREME COURT NOMINEE WITH
NO EVIDENCE.
NOW THEY'RE NOT APOLOGIZING --
>> KATIE, WE DIDN'T KNOW AT THE
TIME --
>> THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE FOR
WHAT HE SAID.
>> IT WAS OBVIOUS.
>> HE WAS LEAVING A TRAIL OF
DYSFUNCTION WHEREVER HE WENT.
EVERYBODY KNEW IT.
>> HE WAS ARRESTED DURING THAT
TIME.
REMEMBER?
>> I'M SAYING, HE WAS ON TV AND
HE WAS A MEMBER -- I DON'T KNOW
IF HE'S STILL A MEMBER OF THE
BAR.
>> HE GOT KICKED OUT OF HIS LAW
FIRM.
>> YOU GUYS WANTED TO
DISCREDIT --
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO DISCREDIT
HIM.
>> IT'S THE MEDIA'S JOB --
YOU'RE DOING IT RETROACTIVELY.
>> TO YOUR POINT, WE DESERVE
CREDIT FOR CALLING OUT AVENATTI,
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
ESPECIALLY TUCKER CARLSON WHO
CALLED HIM THE CREEPY PORN
LATER.
HE GOT -- TUCKER DESERVES A PAT
ON THE BAT AND EVERYBODY AT CNN